[Music]
you must be the one and only Dracula
there's something about an accent that
makes a man sound so intelligent there
is something about that woman I don't
trust Selina in the film your characters
got a little bit of your spidey sense
kind of trigger to Balak Kathryn Hahn
character you're not sure about her in
your old life how's your how's your real
spidey sense like how do you follow your
intuitions ah depends on what day yeah
no but I think I'd like to soon decent
discernment but I I mean I come from a
separated family so I used to get very
protective over my parents and they
would date I mean it would throw me off
and I had to kind of had to give them a
little bit of a test right right right
right
you're always checking out for half
cubed Adam of course how are you Andy
I can always snake in the grass these
movies I'm sure were a blast for you to
do you know before you had a child yes
but now I mean is it does it bring even
a new like it even have more of a
meaning to you yes we're not showing her
anything like that yet she's still too
young but I'm glad to know that I have
made at least one thing she can launch
before the age of 16 your little sister
yeah just truth fine does it run does
she watch it yes did she recognize your
voice yeah yeah well she's my biggest
supporter I should give me any feedback
what is she said about this she's
awesome she's just there to have a good
time I don't think my sister over thinks
anything else
she enjoys it she's excited about life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]